pokerstars est moins naturel remake qui
se ressent rien du tout elle a un jeu
varié tous ces tournois arbres pour
l'écran religion un certain franc de
danse ou de soute la paix en soi c'est
vachement important tombe à hésiter la
pelouse de l'as bien ça voilà c'est
super ça regarde gb qui sort à la
patiente est rien les toiles à des
supers il sort de la terre super g super
beau ça
ouah il reste bien le blanc reste bien
dedans on va tourner autour de gaffe à
l'ombre attention on pouvait toujours un
groupe de ragga force de sa lourdeur des
capteurs c'est un authentique un taux de
co2 à la voile à contre jour normalement
pas derrière ce loin selon golos superbe
ça c'est superbe
loba gaulle au sol est noël plutôt sedan
joue bien on voit la terre en impasse
soit pas trop c'est aussi le superbe
temps sans que penser goma sous un peu
là il ya un côté comme de l'autre
maintenant l'un l'autre ou là que déjà
l'allemagne à quoi fabien fout là il n'y
a pas la mise au point là si c'est bon
ana hina contrevenait bien que votre
cinquième temps c'est bien dedans encore
rien perdre en la matière c'est super
pour savoir c'est super beau ça fait
bien trop bien le faire ça c'est
important d'être bouger enfin vous êtes
net de sullens 13 côte à côte dans ce
flou le dans aia quoi pour garder la foi
pour garder la terre regardez la faire
parce que l'afrique est forcément un peu
molle ce que c'est que ça pourquoi
retour au sort tout doucement de dents
voilà c'est vachement beau et très chaud
qui s'est superposée la vie rurale va
sortir du sol avait pas de shooter et
s'est pas trompé
ok mais heureuse où sort de là peut-être
dommage moi regardez la tête et louis ii
de gueule quand aztèque 5e voire encore
le super bowl se plaint pas trop sous la
mère d'un ado lattes hockey de toulon
père dominateur qui sortent un louis
gergorin et au feu au patro verticale de
théâtre aux patrons verticale dessus
hein j'ai reçu ce fait bien plus tu as à
me trouver cela très serré peut-être sur
le sur le sur le mouvement que voilà ça
c'est super 12 tout on regarde regarde
regarde ses pouces
voilà que toi tu t'écartes doucement
l'adresse est peu plus le bien vivre ce
truc là il ya trop d'écarts doucement
que tu vois pas
énergie qui semble perroquets des
faucons pesante l'énergie on sent que
ces deux-là perroquet c'est l'énergie
c'est la puissance aux livres vêtements
viol un produit très serré on avait dit
qu'on peut résister récit qu'on 20 ans
michal on va faire un plan comme ça on
va penser à arrêter besoin de sortir
l'énergie qui sort de la terre entre les
tirs et il a renchéri gilles vasseur et
michel dessus stu le guide tiré dessus
bien sûr le voilà alors oui je n'ai pas
compris que tu étais là je vois que tu
étais plus mais c'est beau de le rester
qu'on va bien la terre de jaccottet
inconscience apple c'est la touche
loulou enfin bon c'est bon tout ça que
l'odeur michel
voilà encore pitié parce qu'on va faire
briefer savais pas que j'avais vraiment
la faire sortir la voilà voilà voilà
voilà
regardez bien la terre à droite et là la
pub et 1 go je consens tenir le pouce
ben voilà reste encore à doucement
restant comme ça doucement restant en
temps là-dessus montant être si voilà
bien latéral gauche
voila voila patron de terra go soit sur
la cub et voilà encore chercher de
l'argent qu'on pense pouvoir tikal
gauche
ok
mais bon pas ça on va faire les pires a
pu aussi à l'époque en tombe bien c'est
bon ça
pour
oui car elles chutent when we are too
much better to be on the beach boys
alors là dessus on va tous rentrer dans
ce cas voilà
ce qui est très bien chanter juste vingt
quand tu vois le roncquois vas-y pas de
sion on s'en va là à vue barbin c'est
bon c'est bon voilà c'est dit pas si la
fumée on a découvert la terre derrière
ces magnifiques mairie ok là on va y
aller là où je voulais faire les
derniers plans c'est maintenant c'est
bon c'est bon le mouvement de m voilà
ceci peut arborer la soupe de sucre joue
souvent au dessus au dessus voilà super
beau voilà restant ce cadre là c'est
super beau voilà toujours dessus qu'on
va le truc qui sera utile ratant la
fumée s'il te plaît se penche pas ce qui
peut nous paraissent de suarez dessous
milieu de l'image
alors ok bah oui ou oui les autres les
bacs
ouais fantastique let go away aux
canettes go obama est un moment très
très bon